jean marc sylvestre bonjour bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin dans
la matinale verte et france alors
quelles sont exactement les pistes
envisagées par les hôteliers
restaurateurs pour garder leur personnel
vous savez la situation du secteur avait
pas très brillantes mais elle est très
simple à comprendre les hôteliers
restaurateurs ont supporté la crise
grâce aux aides gouvernementales les en
conviennent mais quand les confinements
été levé un peu avant l'été la plupart
des hôteliers restaurateurs n'ont pas
récupéré leurs clients tout de suite
mais surtout beaucoup n'ont pas récupéré
leurs salariés ça c'est beaucoup plus
grave vous avez plus de 300 mille
salariés qui ont complètement disparu
dans la nature ils ont abandonné le
secteur on sait pas où ils sont alors
certains s'y sont restés au chômage ils
ont changé le métier sur inscrits en
formation bocco c'est un secteur où il y
avait plus de 1 million 300 mille
salariés avant la crise ils sont moins
de 1 million aujourd'hui plus grave
encore depuis sept ou huit mois les
hôteliers restaurateurs ne trouve pas de
personnel à rembaucher pour les
remplacer donc vous avez à peu près un
tiers des restaurants aujourd'hui qu'ils
n'ouvrent pas ou alors qu'ils ouvrent
très partiellement alors les
professionnels du secteur ont essayé de
savoir de connaître les vraies raisons
de cette pénurie ils ont quand même pas
une mal à les trouver le métier très dur
c'est vrai il ya des week-ends ou très
peu les salaires sont maigres n'y a pas
d'horaire entre 1000 et 2000 euros de
salaire c'est quand même pas épais d'où
l'idée de booster les pouvoirs les
pourboires vous savez le président a vu
qu'on avait parlé mais bon ça ça ne
marchera pas parce que les sommes sont
très faibles mais d'où l'idée aussi de
modifier les horaires les contrats là
c'est déjà mieux il ya des restaurateurs
qui ont fait preuve d'imagination nous
l'idée enfin de majorer le salaire on
parle de 6 et 10% avec un 13e mois tout
ça serait à négocier mais c'est pas
négligeable parce que ça permettrait de
lisser les salaires à des niveaux de
2005 3000 euros c'est quand même
beaucoup mieux pour les pour les
personnels concernés et ils sont
beaucoup plus atteints et beaucoup plus
que vous prend favorable à les prendre
c'est néanmoins réalisable jean-marc
sans risque économique pour le secteur
oui oui c'est réalisable oui bien sûr
dans les restaurants j'allais dire
parisien dans les restaurants
de la côte atlantique ou de la
méditerranée on l'a vu à vue c'est
évidemment possible d'autant que les
restaurateurs peuvent jouer sur les prix
certains ont déjà augmenté un peu leur
prix on l'a bien vu cet été pendant les
vacances dans les restaurants les plus
modestes qui sont ouvert le midi par
exemple pour pour les travailleurs qu'on
paye parfois avec des tickets
restaurants mais dont l'addition dépasse
pas 10 ou 15 euros ça va être beaucoup
plus difficile compliqué pour une raison
c'est que ces restaurants n'ont pas
retrouvé leur clientèle qui est
désormais en télétravail à peu près on a
perdu à peu près entre un tiers et la
moitié des travailleurs dans une région
comme la région parisienne donc oui les
restos les hôtels de province vont en
sortant risque de craquer il était
malade avant d'ailleurs au dissimuler
leurs difficultés avec un peu de travail
familial et puis disons le un peu de
travail non déclaré quand même pas mal
de blagues latin alors fait remarquer ce
que l'augmentation des salaires est
généralisable à d'autres sectes à la
réponse est oui mais bien sûr ferait pas
dans tous les secteurs qui sont en
tension et qui ne trouvent pas embaucher
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus de
travail que de demandeurs d'emploi donc
il va falloir monter les prix c'est
logique il va falloir monter les prix
dans le digital par exemple a déjà
commencé les développeurs ça c'est une
race que très rares très prisés ils sont
les rois du pétrole aujourd'hui dans le
bâtiment dans le second oeuvre on
recherche des électriciens chauffagistes
on recherche plein de spécialité dans le
commerce digital aussi dans le commerce
de détail dans la réparation automobile
savez vous que dans la carrosserie il ya
plus de carrossier ici en france alors
j'ai une enquête récente là qui indique
que 9 recruteurs sur 10 sont prêts à
augmenter le salaire pour convaincre un
candidat accepté le job 9 sur 10 le
salaire est redevenu le sujet central
alors c'est pas la seule condition pour
accepter un travail il faut que
l'entreprise plaisent bien sûr faut que
l'ambiance le sens l'organisation les
horaires mais on revient très souvent
aux salaires et à ses avantages annexes
je parlais les tickets restaurant oui
des indemnités kilométriques par exemple
toutes les formes et de l'intéressement
les mutuelles très important la mutuelle
sortir de la crise de sanitaires on
s'est aperçu que
finalement on n'avait pas ce n'était pas
tellement bien couverts la crise
sanitaire n'a pas changé l'ordre des
facteurs de décision cette étude indique
que 90 % des candidats à l'embauché ont
quand même une idée très précise du
salaire même s'ils en parlent pas ils
des précise du salaire qui veulent
obtenir alors si j'ai l'employeur me
lapp aussi de la très sympa cette idée
là bas il va faire une offre qui va être
décalés par rapport au projet il
trouvera pas de salarié ça veut dire que
les salariés ont aujourd'hui un pouvoir
de négociation très fort
incontestablement actuellement c'est
quand même une période assez béni pour
les salariés mais encore faut-il qu'ils
aient une formation parce que je parle
pas de tous les s'arrête une expertise
et qu'ils aient envie de travailler le
vrai problème en france ce sont les
seniors qu'on a mis à la retraite un peu
trop vite et puis les jeunes qui n'ont
ni formation ni éducation ni jobs est
très souvent pas de famille pour les
aider alors ça vous savez dans les pays
anglo saxons les appelle les niches on
n'en parle pas beaucoup ils sont plus
d'un million en france et ça c'est un
vrai drame merci beaucoup jean-marc
l'édito écoute jean marc sylvestre c'est
tous les mêmes feuilles matin dans la
matinale de france merci jean marc